Das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir hatten einen Umsatz von 16 Millionen Euro und wir hatten ungefähr, ich sag mal, Verbindlichkeiten in der Größenordnung von 25 Millionen. Meine Aufgabe ist es nicht, jeden Wunsch zu erfüllen. Meine Aufgabe ist es, jeden Wunsch zu erfüllen, wenn man ihn erfüllen kann. Natürlich fragt der eine, warum gehst du nach China? Aber ich glaube, das haben sehr, sehr, das haben alle verstanden, dass das etwas ist, um Möglichkeiten der Zukunft auszuloten, um zum Beispiel die Eigenständigkeit im Verein zu bewahren. Oder wir würden uns zurückziehen, wir sagen, jetzt machen wir Borussia Mönchengladbach nichts mehr mit China. Das ist doch lächerlich.
Na, warum? Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch Nummer 39. Mein Name ist Max Jacob Ost, ich bin der Genetzer auf Twitter. Ihr habt ihn im Intro schon gehört. Wir hatten die große Freude, mit Stephan Schippers sprechen zu dürfen. Er ist Geschäftsführer von Borussia Mönchengladbach, und zwar nicht erst seit vorgestern, sondern seit ziemlich genau 20 Jahren. Er ist außerdem Aussichtsratsmitglied in der DFL und er ist Mitglied im DFB-Vorstand. All das hat dazu geführt, dass wir ein paar Fragen mit ihm besprechen wollten. Was macht man denn zum Beispiel als Geschäftsführer? Und die Interviews mit ihm sind so rar gesät, dass ihr jetzt auch im Intro ausnahmsweise mal schon Dinge gehört habt, die jetzt in der Folge gesagt werden. Normalerweise suche ich da ja immer andere O-Töne zusammen. Stephan Schippers steht nicht so gerne in der Öffentlichkeit und deswegen freuen wir uns sehr, dass er sich für den Rasenfunk dann über eine Stunde Zeit genommen hat. Man kann natürlich nicht alle Themen ansprechen in dieser einen Stunde, aber wir hoffen, dass dennoch ein sehr interessantes Gespräch für euch herausgekommen ist und damit schon mal Danke fürs Einschalten. Diejenigen, die den Rasenfunk vielleicht jetzt zum ersten Mal hören, wir sprechen auch über die Bundesliga, wir sprechen auch über internationale Ligen und vor allem, wir sind Sponsoren und paywall-frei und deswegen, bevor es losgeht, danke ich noch ein paar Menschen exklarisch für ganz viele Supporterinnen und Supporter. Nämlich in dieser Folge sind das Severus Tape, Daniel Pflege, Dorian, Jakob, Stechos Cactus, Rob, Günther Graß-Narbe, Philipp und Sebastian. Sie alle unterstützen den Rasenfunk finanziell und schaffen es, dass es den Rasenfunk gibt und dass er ebenso unabhängig bleiben kann, wie er aktuell ist. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Und das ist jetzt eine Besonderheit. In dieser Folge kann ich auch ankündigen, es gibt auch jetzt einen anderen Weg uns zu unterstützen, nicht nur über direkte Überweisung, ihr könnt auch Merch vom Rasenfunk kaufen. Unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de haben wir faire, schicke, schöne Sachen hergestellt, die ihr kaufen könnt und ein kleiner Beitrag des Preises ist dann eben auch Unterstützung des Rasenfunk vielleicht ja auch etwas für Geburtstage, Weihnachten und so weiter und so fort. Aber jetzt würde ich sagen, hören wir auf mit dem Gespräch über den Rasenfunk. Wie wichtig ist das, was Stephan Schippers zu sagen hatte? Hören wir ins Gespräch rein und bitte. Stephan Schippers, freut mich sehr, dass Sie im Rasenfunk mit dabei sind. Herzlich willkommen.
Da ist es gut, sich positioniert zu haben.
Da musst du dich positionieren, weil der eine oder andere ist vielleicht schon besetzt, der eine oder andere größere Verein. Am langen Ende ist es auch noch eine Aufgabe, als Verein mit Ambitionen immer mal wieder auch international spielen zu wollen, dass man sagt, ich halte die Fahne des deutschen Fußballs auch zum Beispiel in China hoch.
Das ist alles gut verständlich und da ist ja die Borussia auch bei weitem nicht exklusiv, nach China zu gehen. Jetzt ist China aber nicht nur ein Markt, sondern an der Stelle würde mich auch noch interessieren, welche Rolle spielen denn dann nichtökonomische Faktoren bei solchen Entscheidungen? Also zum Beispiel, das kam jetzt vor zwei Wochen, glaube ich, öffentlich, die China-Cabes, wo herauskam, dass über eine Million Uiguren eine muslimische, weitgehend muslimische Minderheit in China in Umerziehungslagern einkassiniert wird. Wir sprechen ja nicht nur vom Markt China, sondern daran hängen ja noch andere Aspekte. Und ohne, dass ich jetzt sagen möchte, jeder Fußballverein muss ein Exempel statuieren. Wir sind alle in einem größeren Kontext eingebettet, aber das gehört ja mit dazu. Und die Borussia steht ja auch für gewisse Werte, die vielleicht nicht immer von den Märkten, in die man da eintritt, und da rede ich jetzt in dem Fall von China, so repräsentiert werden. Was sind ihre Gedanken zu solchen Überlegungen?
Also Sie haben auf der einen Seite, haben Sie ja Recht, indem Sie die Frage stellen. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es so, dass wir als Beispiel, wir als Borussia Mönchengladbach jetzt, wo wir nach China gehen und das tun, was wir gut tun, nämlich Jungs und Mädchens fußballerisch auszubilden, also das, was wir am besten hier zu Hause in Mönchengladbach machen, auch nach China tragen, zu einer Art Völkerverständigung beitragen. Sie haben ja 100 Prozent Recht, vielleicht ist das ja nicht abschließend. Aber der Sport kann Brücken bauen, und genau muss der Sport Brücken bauen. Aber sich wegzuducken als Sport, zu sagen, weil etwas passiert, was wir nicht gut finden, was nicht gut ist, in dem einen oder anderen Bereich, ohne es werten zu wollen, zu sagen, dann schließe ich das aus. Dann kommt man gar nicht weiter. Es gibt ein wunderschönes Beispiel. Es gibt ein wunderschönes Beispiel. Borussia Mönchengladbach war die erste Mannschaft, die nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg mit einer Militärmaschine nach Israel geflogen ist und Fußball gemacht hat. Wir waren Botschafter über den Fußball. Und wenn man es so sehen will, ist das genau richtig, denn der Sport, der Fußball, kann Brücken schlagen. Der Fußball ist nicht für alles verantwortlich, aber er kann Brücken schlagen. Natürlich kann ich alles negative der Welt immer abstrahieren, immer nur auf… und der Fußball muss es richten. Da ist der Fußball überfordert. Aber die Brücken, die er geschlagen hat, die sind, glaube ich, wichtig und richtig. Aber trotzdem, eh die Diskussion weitergeht. Borussia Mönchengladbach hat sich immer auf die Fahne geschrieben, und das können sie auch wunderbar lesen, für Toleranz. Wir sind unpolitisch. Wir beziehen keine Stellung, denn welche Stellung ist richtig? Entscheidet das der jeweilige der Geschäftsführer, Präsident, Trainer? Soll das der entscheiden? Borussia Mönchengladbach ist unpolitisch. Borussia Mönchengladbach hat die Arme offen für jede Art der Konfession. Jeder Fan, der es uns liebt. Ob es die Hautfarbe, die Herkunft ist. Das ist der Sport. Und dann verbindet der Sport.
Finden Sie nicht, dass man sich da dann auch positionieren müsste, ohne dass – ich fordere jetzt nicht das Extrem, dass ich jetzt sage, Sie müssen, weil jetzt diese Unterdrückung der Uiguren und auch andere Dinge aus China bekannt wurden, nicht Ihr Büro schließen. Aber muss man sich da nicht auch positionieren, um zu verhindern, dass das, was Sie ja auch tun, nämlich eben dem China, zusammen mit dem DFB, Fußball-Know-How zu geben für das Ziel, was China in sportlichem Hinsicht verfolgt, nämlich mal 20 bis 2040, glaube ich, eine WM teilzunehmen und sie wollen auch mal selbst eine ausrichten. Das, was Sie da tun, das spielt ja gleichzeitig dem bestehenden politischen System in China in den Karten. Wir wissen ja, dass der Sport nicht so unpolitisch ist, dass er nicht auch seine Strahlkraft genutzt werden würde. Da müssen wir ja nicht mal bis nach China gehen. Da können wir ja ganz viele andere Beispiele sehen. Wäre es da nicht wichtig, dann auch mal einen Gegenakzent zu setzen, ohne gleich alle Brücken abzubrechen? Das will ich ja gar nicht.
Nochmal, wir bewegen uns jetzt auf einer politischen Diskussion, wo ich…
Aber wenn es um Menschenrechte geht, weiß ich nicht, ob wir so parteipolitisch sind oder ob das nicht…
Nein, das ist, wir bewegen uns ja jetzt in einer Fragestellung, die sehr schwer zu beantworten ist, weil du als Vertreter von Borussia, eines Fußballklubs, eines deutschen Fußballklubs, der dann auch noch in China vor Ort ist, eine Antwort geben sollst. Und ich glaube, die Antwort des Brückenbauens und nämlich des Ankommens bei demjenigen, bei dem Jungen, bei dem Mädchen, bei den Fußballerinnen und Fußballern, das ist ja schon mal ein Riesenschritt. Das ist ja schon mal die Brücke, die gebaut wird. Und jetzt frage ich ganz ketzerlich, was wäre es denn, wenn wir uns positionieren und sagen, wir finden das nicht gut? Das wird nicht böse gemeint, das würde irgendwo verpuffen.
Ja, das wäre aber vielleicht…
Oder wir würden uns zurückziehen, wir sagen, wir, jetzt machen wir Borussia Mönchengladbach nichts mehr mit China. Ist doch lächerlich.
Na, warum? Wäre das nicht vielleicht genau das?
Dann sind wir auf einem Pfad, dass wir sagen würden, die politische Diskussion A, die lohnt es sich zu sprechen und die politische Diskussion B lohnt es sich vielleicht nicht zu sprechen. Aber das ist eine Wertung. Deswegen wollte ich das Verständnis, sagen wir, schüren. Bei uns in unserem Kodex, den wir bei Borussia Mönchengladbach haben, das ist der Borussenkodex, 2.0 sogar, den haben die Fänz sich gegeben. Und da drin ist verankert, wir sind unpolitisch. Das ist dann schwer. Wenn man vielleicht Sachen, die man selber privat anders entscheiden würde, aber aufgrund der Gesinnung dieses Vereines dann so zu gestalten, denn vielleicht ist ja, jetzt lasst mal bitte mal China weg, es gibt andere politische Diskussionen, dann sagen sie vielleicht, das finde ich gut, ich sage, ich fände das genauso gut. Aber es gibt immer einen Gegenpol, der sagt, ne, aber das darf Borussia auf keinen Fall machen.
Den gibt es definitiv, aber vielleicht gibt es ja einen gemeinsamen Nenner und damit würde ich dann auch jetzt zum Schluss kommen, auch wenn ich noch lange mit ihnen reden könnte.
Steht oben wunderbar.
Gegen Rassismus für Toleranz.
Und für Borussia. Das steht bei uns unterm Tribünen-Dach und das sind so die wichtigen Werte.
Genau, das ist der gemeinsame Nenner, auf den ich hin wollte, die Menschenrechte. Und da würde mich jetzt noch als abschließendes Thema interessieren, Sie haben ja gerade auch noch eine andere große Aufgabe vor sich, nämlich einen neuen Trikotsponsor zu finden, wo sich mir persönlich die Frage stellt, was ist schwieriger, diese Aufgabe zu erfüllen oder deutscher Meister zu werden?
Also ganz im Ernst, es ist eine spaßige Frage, Sie kriegen eine spaßige Antwort, aber nein, lassen Sie bitte, jeder kann träumen, aber am 13. Spieltag träumt Borussia nicht von der deutschen Meisterschaft.
Wir wollen jetzt hier keine Meisterschaftsschleppseile raus. Aber spielen denn dann solche Überlebungen, wie ich sie hatte, bei denen mir völlig klar ist, ich komme jetzt aus einer komplett anderen Einflugschneise, als Sie in Ihrem kaufmännischen Denken logischerweise haben. Aber spielen solche Überlegungen auch bei der Auswahl eines Trikot-Sponsors eine Rolle, der ja den prominentesten Platz bei einem Fußballverein neben dem Stadion hat. Und da haben Sie sich schon festgelegt, das wird nicht passieren. Das hier wird der Borussia-Park bleiben, allerhöchstens mal vielleicht ein Zusatz. Aber spielen da solche Überlegungen auch eine Rolle, dass man sagt, zum Beispiel wir wollen nur mit Unternehmen zusammenarbeiten, die sich dem Aktionsplan für UN-Menschenrechte sich einzusetzen angeschlossen haben, den ja auch die deutsche Bundesregierung initiiert hat.
Also sie haben vollkommen recht. Man sollte auf jeden Fall – oder das macht Borussia Mönchengladbach – neben dem Geld, worum es sich fast immer nur geht, dreht in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung, ist der Hauptsponsor ein Bestandteil vom Club, der dringt stark in deine DNA ein. Und der Hauptsponsor will ja auch, dass das, was Borussia Mönchengladbach verkörpert, dass das auch auf ihn strahlt. Deswegen muss ein Sponsoring immer auf Augenhöhe sein. Ich kann das ganz klar beantworten. Es gibt verschiedene Farben. Dann ist das halt so auf der einen Seite. Die Diskussionen haben wir geführt. Aber du musst schon Unternehmen haben, die zu dir passen am langen Ende. Und das impliziert dann ihre Fragestellung.
Also das heißt, sie haben das auf dem Schirm und man denkt dann auch so.
Heutzutage ist das Gewinnen eines Hauptsponsors ja gar nicht mehr nur das Gewinnen eines Partners, der dir Geld gibt für Präsenzen, sei es auf der Brust, auf den Banden oder wo auch immer. Sondern am langen Ende kann er dich auf ganz anderen Gebieten auch viel weiterbringen. Was weiß ich, wenn wir über Digitalisierung reden und dergleichen. Dann sind das vielleicht Softfacts, die am Ende des Tages sich viel mehr auszahlen.
Dann bin ich sehr gespannt, was Sie da präsentieren werden, wann auch immer. Manche Hörerinnen und Hörer werden das hier bestimmt erst hören, wenn der Trikotsponsor schon verkündet wurde. Sagen Sie mir abschließend noch die Borussia Mönchengladbach im Jahr 2030. Wie sieht die Bundesliga aus und welche Rolle spielt Borussia da losgelöst von Tabellenplätzen? Mir geht es jetzt nicht um irgendwelche Titelfragen, sondern wie stellen Sie sich das Geschäft Fußball in zehn Jahren vor?
Erstmal hoffe ich, dass der Fußball Fußball bleibt. Ich hoffe, dass wir gerade, wenn wir über die Champions League sprechen, nicht darüber sprechen, dass das Qualifizieren zur Champions League fundamentiert zementiert ist, so wie es gerade von der ECR so ein wenig in Fokus genommen worden ist, sondern dass gerade der Ausgang in der jeweiligen Nationalen Liga die Qualifikation zur Champions League, zur Euro League ausmacht. Das Brot- und Buttergeschäft soll der Fußball, der nationale Fußball bleiben, die Bundesliga, der DFB-Pokal, alles das, was wir so lieben. Und die Sahne, das Sahnehäubchen obendrauf, das sind die internationalen Wettbewerbe und die musst du erreichen über den nationalen Liga-Ausgang am Ende einer Saison. Das ist ein wesentlicher Bestandpunkt und dass wir im Endeffekt den Fußball, so wie wir ihn haben, auch weiterhin lieben können.
Okay, das war jetzt eine halbe Antwort, aber weil wir schon drüber über die Zeit sind, lasse ich sie damit davon kommen. Ich hätte noch ganz lange mit ihm weitersprechen können. Vielen herzlichen Dank, Stephan Schippers.
Danke, tschüss. Sehr gerne, tschüss.
Und da war es vorbei, unser Gespräch mit Stephan Schippers. Viel zu schnell natürlich, vor allem für eingefleischte Rasenfunkhörerinnen und Hörer. Aber so ist das eben. Man kann nicht mit jedem vier Stunden sprechen, auch wenn man es definitiv mit jedem gerne machen würde und es auch jeder Gesprächsgast verdient hätte, wie ich finde. Wer weiß, vielleicht gibt es ja irgendwann mal einen Teil zwei. Wir hoffen, dass euch dieser – na ja, fast schon Quickie – in Tribünengespräch ausmaßen dennoch gefallen hat, dass ihr interessante neue Dinge erfahren habt. Und einen Hinweis möchte ich noch gerne machen. Am Ende von allen Folgen weise ich gerne auf Podcast-Episoden hin, die mir gut gefallen haben. Und da hat Stephan Schippers die Überleitung und den Anstoß für gegeben, was ich hier im Tribünengespräch empfehlen könnte. Erinnert ihr euch an den Moment, in dem er gesagt hat, dass Borussia Mönchengladbach die erste Mannschaft war, die aus Gründen der Volkeverständigung nach Israel gefahren ist und dort Spiele bestritten hat? Diese Information hatte ich schon. Warum hatte ich die? Dafür ist allein ein Podcast verantwortlich, nämlich Mensch, Frau Nora. Sowieso ein sehr empfehlenswertes Format. Und in der Folge Diplomaten in kurzen Hosen mit Jessica Baller, die jetzt auch neulich in der Schlusskonferenz, also wenn ihr das jetzt zeitnah hört, ihr Debüt gegeben hat im Rasenfunk, wurde genau diese Episode aufgearbeitet. Kann ich euch allen sehr, sehr ans Herz legen. Eine sehr tolle Folge lohnt sich und es ist ja auch ein interessantes Stück Sportgeschichte. Ja und damit sind wir am Ende dieses 39. Tribünengesprächs angelangt. Wenn ihr Lust habt, könnt ihr jetzt natürlich auch unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de shoppen. Ihr könnt den Rasenfunk anders unterstützen unter rasenfunk.de/. Unterstützen gibt es alle Informationen dazu und sollte euch der Rasenfunk bisher neu gewesen sein, dann guckt doch mal, was wir sonst noch so viele Folgen gemacht haben. Es würde mich wundern, wenn da nicht für jeden was dabei wäre. Über 800 Stunden Rasenfunk. Macht es gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Bis bald mal wieder.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.